multiplica y expresa el resultado como
una expresión racional simplificada
indica cuál es el dominio que hay
entonces pues primero vamos a hacer la
multiplicación y después antes de
simplificar esta multiplicación vamos a
decir cuál es el dominio
entonces esta multiplicación es
numerador por numerador o sea a cuadrada
menos 4 por a más 1 que supere esto por
esto entre a cuadrada menos uno por a
más 2
a cuadrada menos 1 por a más 2
ahora este a cuadrada menos cuatro y
éste a cuadrada menos uno seguro te
saltan a la vista porque seguro ya los
reconoces y los has visto un montón de
veces estos términos son unas
diferencias de cuadrados aunque hay si
tenemos aquí a cuadrada menos b cuadrada
esta diferencia de cuadrados nosotros
sabemos que es igual a menos b por a más
b
entonces podemos factorizar esta
expresión y nos queda que este término
es igual a más 2 porque 2 al cuadrado es
por a menos 2 ok si en algún momento te
preguntas qué por qué funciona hacer
esto pues simplemente haz la
multiplicación entre estos dos términos
y vas a ver que te da a cuadrada menos 4
bueno pero en el numerador también
tenemos por aquí el a más 1 entonces
tenemos que escribirlo
entre este término de aquí que es
a más 1 por a menos 11 al cuadrado es 1
y nos falta el término b a más 2 a más 2
bueno ahora vamos a ordenar el numerador
y el denominador para que sea más claro
cuáles términos se van a cancelar con
cuáles entonces pues empecemos por aquí
esta multiplicación es igual a a más 2 y
una vez vamos a escribir el a más 2 en
el denominador y pregunta hay algún otro
término en el numerador que también está
en el denominador sí y aquí por ejemplo
está el amazon o no entonces vamos con
él a más 1
a más
no en el numerador y en el denominador
también está a ver ya escribimos a este
que es este y escribimos a este que es
este y también en el denominador
escribimos a este o sea que ya lo vamos
a subrayar y escribimos también a este
entonces ya nada más nos falta poner a
este ya este o sea que nos falta
escribir aquí a menos 2 y en el
denominador está a menos 1
y ahora antes de ponernos a cancelar
estas cosas es un muy buen momento para
determinar cuál es el dominio y en el
dominio ponemos a todos los números
excepto aquellos números que hacen que
esta expresión racional esté
indeterminada y como hemos visto antes
esto solo pasa cuando el denominador se
hace cero y para que se haga cero a más
dos tienen que ser igual a cero o a más
uno tiene que ser igual a cero o a menos
uno tiene que ser igual a cero porque
hay con estas ecuaciones podemos
encontrar qué números hacen que esta
expresión se inter min y justo tenemos
que quitar esos valores de a del dominio
aunque entonces podemos resolver estas
ecuaciones y pues aquí para que además
12 igual a 0 podemos restar dos de los
dos lados y nos queda que hace que el
denominador sea cero si es igual a menos
si es igual a menos 1 o si es igual a 1
entonces a tiene que ser distinta de
menos 2 menos uno y uno para que el
denominador sea distinto de cero y no se
determine esta expresión racional
ok entonces tenemos que agregar la
restricción de que a tiene que ser
distinto de menos 2 - 2 - 1 - 1 y 1
ok nuestro dominio son todos los reales
excepto menos 2 - 1 y 1 y ahora si ya
podemos simplificar esta expresión
racional como a más 2 es distinto de 0 y
el denominador está muy bien determinado
entonces éste se cancela con este
y lo mismo pasa con además uno esté
amazon o se cancela con este amazona y
nos queda simplemente a menos 2 / a
menos 1 entonces esta multiplicación de
expresión y racionales termina siendo
simplemente a menos 2 entre a menos 1
gay ahora que no se nos olvide agregar
la restricción de que a tiene que ser
distinto de menos 2 - 1 y 1
ok bueno tú aquí me podrías preguntar
cuál es el problema de poner a igual a
menos uno o sea si sustituimos a igual a
menos uno en el denominador nos queda
menos dos y no se determina esta
fracción bueno pero nosotros queremos
que esta expresión sea igualita a esta
otra expresión y a igual a menos uno
hace que esta expresión se determine y
si a no es distinto de menos uno o sea
si a más uno puede ser igual a cero
entonces no podemos cancelar estos
términos aunque aquí sustituyendo el a
igual a menos uno aquí en el denominador
nos queda nada más menos dos como en
esta otra expresión no podemos poner a
igual a menos uno porque se determinó
entonces para que estas dos cosas sean
iguales tenemos que restringir a que a
tiene que ser distinto de menos uno para
asegurar que estas dos expresiones sean
iguales y no simplemente que sean muy
cerca